[Musique]
dans l'actualité de ce 3 février la date
du scrutin se fait attendre mais la
campagne elle a bien débuté à
mantes-la-jolie les tension ne retombe
pas après la démission du maire sur fond
de divisions de la majorité
les anciens alliés se font aujourd'hui
face le point sur cette situation
fin du télétravail obligatoire fin du
masque à l'extérieur les mesures contre
la propagation de lakovic 19 sont
allégées mais est ce une bonne chose la
réponse de l' agence régionale de santé
à suivre 1,7 milliard d'euros
supplémentaires pour le prolongement à
l'ouest du rer e un montant qui
interpelle les élus le directeur du
projet s'explique à partir d'aujourd'hui
devant une mission menée par la région
d'île de france et puis le changement
climatique sujet souvent abordé mais pas
toujours bien compris sans former pour
comprendre justement c'était le thème de
l'intervention de valérie
masson-delmotte coprésidente du giec
hier à la maison de l'environnement de
saint quentin en yvelines nous l'avons
rencontrée
[Musique]
alors que le maire de mantes-la-jolie a
démissionné la date du scrutin se fait
attendre tour d'horizon des candidats à
la municipale partielle actuellement
adjoint au maire à l'urbanisme jean luc
santini est soutenu par le président du
département des yvelines pierre bédier
il peut également compter sur 31 élus
municipaux
de son côté raphaël cogner a quant à lui
décidé de repartir à la reconquête de sa
ville il peut compter sur certains de
ses anciens adjoints il y aura et du
petit mot un certain nombre d'anciens
élus qui sont restés avec moi qu'à ceux
qui sont déjà là même boire il ya ceux
qui attend que la campagne soit vraiment
lancée dans les deux camps les projets
pour la ville sont quasi similaires si
aujourd'hui on fait une mesure un petit
peu d'urgence pour l'hiver pour les sdf
ça sera dans l'avenir une mesure
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus précise et
puis il ya les deux grands thèmes qui
sont l'anru pour le val fourré et le
coeur de ville pour le pour le centre
ville on peut raisonner par cartier dans
le quartier du val fourré ya évidemment
le plan revu que j'ai lancée puisque
l'heureux était accompagne depuis une
dizaine d'années donc le renouvellement
du quartier du val fourré ça sert
dossier très important
en centre-ville on a le doxie en coeur
de ville avec tout le soutien au
commerce et travail qu'on fait sur les
espaces publics et la mise en valeur de
la nature et de la haie de même
centre-ville qui est un centre ville
magnifique et puis dans le quartier de
gassicourt il ya tout ce que j'ai déjà
fait autour du fait de rendre la nature
plus présentes dans la ville enfin
guillaume quévarec ancien élu municipal
de la ville va mener une liste de gauche
rassemblée france insoumise europe
ecologie les verts et socialistes inédit
à montrent la jolie sans les on est
motivé par c'est qu'effectivement ce qui
se passe sur la ville de mantes-la-jolie
depuis plusieurs mois est assez
destructeur les déplorables et on a
vraiment vu proposer autre chose pour
nous vraiment bédié cogner c'est le
passé bédié cogner c'est dépassé et nous
vraiment on va proposer quelque chose de
positif et nous on présente l'avenir
pour mantes la jolie guillaume quévarec
peut compter sur audrey alliés membres
de la france insoumise jean-paul
carcélès secrétaire de section parti
socialiste à mantes la jolie ou encore
stéphane barnier responsable europe
ecologie les verts à mantes la jolie on
a un axe fort qui pour leur important
pour la ville de mantes la jolie c'est
effectivement tout ce qui est honnête et
et lutte contre la corruption après on a
des enjeux je les dis sur la démocratie
citoyenne et participative pour faire en
sorte que les habitants d'autres villes
et s'implique dans la ville et dans les
projets et puis on a une ville qu il
fracturé une ville avec de grandes
difficultés sociales donc les actions
autour de la solidarité
et puis la réussite éducative des son
côté marc jamais membre du parti
communiste français vient de l'annoncer
il conduira une liste seule lors de la
prochaines municipales partielles
[Musique]
dans le reste de l'actualité de ce 3
février également la levée de certaines
restrictions dans le cadre de la lutte
contre la copie de 19 le port du masque
n'est dorénavant plus obligatoire en
extérieur les jauges dans les lieux
recevant du public assis sont abandonnés
et le télétravail n'est plus que
recommandée dans les yvelines le taux
d'incidence a chuté de 25% sur les sept
derniers jours tout comme le nombre
moyen de nouveaux cas confirmés
quotidien les mesures de qui sont prises
par le gouvernement pour alléger un
petit peu les contraintes qui pèsent sur
nous elles sont basées sur des faits
scientifiques et donc je pense que
par rapport à satiété 6 culation
épidémique qui baisse un peu et puis
pour aussi soulagé je veux dire par là
la patience enfin soulagé la difficulté
pour les français d'avoir toutes ces
contraintes aujourd'hui dans les
yvelines 81,6 % de la population dispose
d'un schéma vaccinal complet 75 % ayant
fait sa dose de rappel et face à cette
évolution de la situation sanitaire les
centres de vaccination s'adapte certains
réduisent les plages horaires comme à
saint quentin en yvelines pendant que
d'autres des ménages c'est le cas du
centre de mantes la jolie dorénavant
installé à magnanville une décision
motivée par la diminution des demandes
mais aussi la nécessité de relancer les
manifestations dans les anciens locaux
les communes nous soutiennent et donc là
jusqu'au 31 décembre la commune augmente
nous a fortement soutenu
et donc mettez à disposition le ménage
les agents de sécurité et l'allemagne en
ville nous remettent pareil à
disposition n'a également le soutien de
gpso la communauté d'agglo aujourd'hui
on va avoir à peu près 300 un peu plus
de 312 de réaliser l'injection en
moyenne 12 car depuis quelques semaines
700-800 trappe à nouveau dans
l'actualité avec la mise en examen du
député européen jordan bardella l'élu du
rassemblement national avait qualifié la
ville de république islamique
elle des propos qu'il a réitéré hier sur
le plateau de c 8 face au maire de la
commune dont il avait demandé la
révocation ainsi que la mise sous
tutelle de la ville je maintiens mes
propos trap est éminemment une petite
république islamique en miniature ce que
je dis c'est que tu rappes roubaix saint
denis la ville où j'ai grandi
et tant d'autres quartiers en france
c'est notre futur sakho si on reprend
par ange en main maintenant la situation
alors ce qu'on connaît à trappes on le
connaîtra demain donc dans
d'innombrables villes françaises le
quart de finale de la coupe de france
opposant bergerac à versailles se jouera
finalement à périgueux mercredi prochain
la fédération française a tranché une
dérogation a été accordée car seuls
bordeaux possédait un stade normalement
homologué pour ce genre de rencontres
dans la région de quoi agacer les
dirigeants et blinois qui au tour
précédent n'avait obtenu aucun passe
droit pour recevoir toulouse
reste maintenant à régler le litige en
chaussant les crampons et en décrochant
une place en demies
chatou nouvelle la référence du street
art deux des six fresques réalisées
l'été dernier viennent d'être
sélectionnés parmi les plus belles de
l'année en france elle participe aux
golden street art 2021 organisé par le
site trompe-l'oeil point info les
internautes vont maintenant pouvoir se
prononcer et mettre la cité des
impressionnistes à l'honneur parmi les
38 autres oeuvres en compétition la
réalisation de vigny graffiti baptisé
diversité orne la façade d'un immeuble
de la résidence des marolles et l'ama
morphose de carlos alberto g h figure à
l'entrée du collège renoir
[Musique]
notre invité valérie masson-delmotte
bonjour bonjour vous êtes
paléoclimatologue directrice de
recherche au laboratoire des sciences du
climat et de l'environnement unités du
cea le commissariat à l'énergie atomique
le cnrs le centre national de la
recherche scientifique et lui vécu
l'université versailles saint quentin
alors vous êtes présente ce soir pour
une rencontre avec le public vous
informer échanger sur le changement
climatique
c'est important pour vous d'échanger
avec le public oui et je pense que ça
fait vraiment partie de nos missions en
fait c'est à dire que la recherche
scientifique s'est pas seulement
produire des connaissances mais c'est
aussi les partager et d'autant plus que
la question du changement climatique la
rue finalement elle concerne tout le
monde
de multiples manières vous écrivez aussi
des ouvrages pour les adultes mais pour
6 pour la jeunesse vous souhaitez vous
adresser à toulouse alors effectivement
donc là je vais superviser un rapport
d'évaluation sur l'état des
connaissances vis-à-vis du changement
climatique donc c'est un document qui en
fait très technique qui est aussi une
construction avec les représentants de
tous les pays qui finalement
reconnaissent ce socle scientifique
commun et puis à côté de sage intervient
alors selon la disponibilité que j'ai
devant le très grand public mais aussi
parfois à la demande d'enseignants
devant des élèves un public scolaire et
pour moi c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement intéressant c'est à dire le
fait de pouvoir entendre les questions
que se posent les gens la manière dont
il se représente le changement
climatique par rapport à ce qu'ils
apprennent à l'école ou bien ce qu'ils
glanent sur les réseaux sociaux dans
l'est libyen c'est quelque chose aussi
qui parfois m'amène moi même un profond
dire méconnaissance par rapport à des
questions qui sont posées et pour
lesquels je vais solliciter des
collègues pour vraiment comprendre
l'état des lieux et puis le transmettre
les lieux possibles ou et puis j'ai vous
adresser quand vous adresse à la
jeunesse à ceux de demain qui vont subir
les effets de ce changement climatique
oui alors j'ai aussi un mois deux filles
qui sont maintenant étudiants afin
qu'ils sont adultes mais c'est vrai que
quand on s'intéresse aux évolutions
futures du climat il s'agit en fait du
monde des jeunes d'aujourd'hui à horizon
2050 un homme est fier au bout de mon
âge donc en fait c'est quelque chose qui
est pas tellement lointain c'est
quelques dizaines d'années dans le futur
et donc faire en sorte que les plus
jeunes
finalement comprennent pourquoi est-ce
qu'on en est là aujourd'hui quels sont
les leviers d'action qui existent pour
vivre avec un climat qui change et puis
pour agir sur la cause du changement je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui est
important parce que le changement
climatique c'est pas quelque chose qui
va disparaître demain on va vivre avec
pendant longtemps et donc du coup c'est
important d'avoir des repères factuels
vraiment rigoureux objectif c'est
important aussi pour former des citoyens
qui ont l'esprit critique par rapport à
ce qu'on peut entendre sur sur ces
sujets alors ce qu'a fait l'actualité
c'était en septembre dernier 2021 il
était rendu le rapport du giec le groupe
d'experts intergouvernemental sur
l'évolution du climat et vous avez été
auditionné une pardon à l'assemblée
nationale sur ce rapport il faut aussi
rapporté au plus haut ce que vous avez
évalué oui donc ce rapport c'était trois
ans de travail avec des centaines de
chercheurs du monde entier et puis
toutes les étapes de relecture pour
s'assurer de la rigueur la qualité la
pertinence de l'évaluation donc c'est un
travail considérable mais c'est un
travail qui n'a de sens que s'il est
partagé donc le fait que par exemple le
les commissions spécialisées sur le
développement durable de l'assemblée
nationale ou du sénat demande à vous
dise youn et les auteurs du rapport - en
tant que coordinatrice le fait que
c'était le cas aussi au parlement
européen par exemple ou dans certains de
conseils municipaux où on a aussi invité
à intervenir en plus en visio c'est plus
facile ça demande un désavantage son
voile à faire c'est valérie
masson-delmotte on pourrait vous écouter
parler pendant des heures et bien sûr
merci à nos téléspectateurs de nous
suivre
[Musique]
et puis l'information à suivre du jour
c'est le début de l' enquête ouverte par
la mission d'information et d'évaluation
du conseil régional d'île de france elle
va devoir comprendre pourquoi le projet
eole ce prolongement du rer e dans les
yvelines coûtera finalement 1,7 milliard
d'euros supplémentaire est la vieille
ruse le directeur d'école vient d'être
entendue 27 personnes le second en tout
il a expliqué la complexité technique du
chantier la porte maillot on n'a pas
réussi à faire descendre l'eau peut-être
que ça avait été prévu au départ c'est
nier scellier seront peut-être la
présence d'argile dans les sables qui
sont en partie basse et ce phénomène
jamais été observé don qui nous a
conduit à devoir déployer des moyens
supplémentaires pour descendre la nappe
défense on a eu des difficultés avec les
bétons j'ai dit qu'on avait était venu
en tenue soulever un bâtiment et les
bétons de ce bâtiment était très
hétérogène on n'avait pas reçu
l'autorisation du propriétaire pour
faire les campagnes de reconnaissance
qu'on aurait souhaité faire il y en a eu
d'autres aléas qui sont allés à d'autres
contextes qu'on a eu notamment de crues
qui ont conduit à l'évacuation des
installations chantier donc ça peut
paraître anecdotique mais quand sur un
chantier vous devez vous arrêter
démonter les installations pourra
revenir des remontées c'est des
perturbations qui sont assez fortes pour
permettre la poursuite des travaux 642
millions d'euros doivent être trouvées
en urgence 421 ont déjà été assurée avec
le concours de sncf réseau de la région
ile de france et des départements des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine les
collectivités attendent désormais une
main tendue de l'état le prolongement du
rer e doit permettre de relier la gare
saint lazare à mantes la jolie
[Musique]